THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DRAWS GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GROW.
HERTZBERG.
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROB [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
LIKE OWSKI [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMORY MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE REAL IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR GUEST
CHAPLAIN.
BISHOP RON ALLEN PHD PASTOR
GREAT SOLOMON TEMPLE COMMUNITY
CHURCH AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
BY THE FOOT OF THE FLAG BY
SENATOR SKINNER [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I ASK YOU TO PRAY FOR ME.
AS I PRAY FOR YOU --
JUST LISTEN TO MY PRAYER I ALSO
NEED YOUR PRAYER [inaudible]
HEAVENLY FATHER.
I COME TO YOU IN THAT NAME
THAT'S ABOVE ALL NAY
[inaudible]
ASKING YOU.
FATHER GOT TO BE OUR SPECIAL
GUEST HERE TODAY WE INVITE CHIU
AND WE'D LIKE TO PRESENCE IN.
TODAY NOT ONLY BE OUR SPECIAL
GUEST TODAY FATHER GOD.
B. ARE FISH YOU GUESSED EVERY
MORNING HERE ON THE FLOOR HELP
US.
TO DECREASE WHY YOU INCREASE IN
OUR LIFE.
LET THEM SEE ALL OF YOU.
AND NONE OF US.
FATHER GOD BE.
A FIFTH AROUND ALL OF THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
BREAST EVERYONE LESTER FAMILIES.
STAFF LESTER LOVE ONE WITH
SUPERNATURAL WISDOM SUPERNATURAL
GRACE.
SUPERNATURAL POWER BE IF IT'S A
PROTECTION AROUND THEM FATHER
GOD.
AS THEY DO YOUR GREAT WORK.
THAT YOU HAVE CALLED THEM TO
THAT YOU HAVE CHOSEN TO DO IN
THIS LIFE.
FATHER GOD GIVE THE ELECTED BODY
OF OFFICIALS YOUR PIECE.
GIVE THEM YOUR LOW [inaudible]
THE BILL.
IN EVERY AREA OF THEIR LIFE.
GO AROUND ABOUT THEM MAKE THEIR
WAY STREET HEAVILY ANGELS.
FATHER GOD WE ASK LORD MASTER.
THAT YOU POUR IN THE M..
POUR INTO THEM WHAT MASTER THAT
THEY MIGHT POUR INTO THEIR
DISTRICT.
MY POOR INTO THE SENATE AND MY
POOR INTO THIS WORLD I PRAY THAT
YOU GRACE AND YOUR MERCY BE UPON
THEM.
FAMILY FATHER WHEN ALL IS SAID
AND DONE.
WE WILL NOT FORGET TO GIVE YOU
ALL THE PRAISE ALL THE GLORY AND
ALL THE HONOR.
WE PUT ALL THESE THINGS.
IN THAT WONDERFUL NAME THAT'S
ABOVE EVERY NAME.
AND EVERYONE SAY A MAY.
MEMBERS IF YOU JOIN WITH ME IN
THE SALUTE TO OUR FLAGS.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL [inaudible]
TWENTY THREE BUT YOU BRING
[inaudible]
FIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WE ARE AT
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
I DON'T HAVE ANY WRITTE DOWN
DOES ANYONE HAVE A PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WHICH
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH THROUGH THE THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO INTRODUCTION
AND FIRST READING OF BILLS.
CENTER SKINNER FOR PURPOSE TO
RISE -- FOR
MOTION RESOLUTION.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
PERTAINING TO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE WHICH I AUTHORED LAST YEAR
THIS LETTER HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER.
INTRODUCTION OF FIRST READING AM
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
I WILL START WITH SENATE THIRD
READING.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ONE SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SEVEN PLEASE MAKE THE
CURRENT RESOLUTION FOR BY
SENATOR GLAZER RELATIVE TO
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WEEK.
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT STR.
FOR MANY OF US HAD THE
MINOR SURGERY.
OR A MAJOR MEDICAL PROCEDURE
THAT REQUIRED ANESTHESIA.
IT CAN BE UNNERVING AND FOR SOME
FRIGHTENING.
WHEN THAT MASS COMES OVER YOUR
FACE AND YOU START DRIFTING INTO
A DEEP SLEEP?
BUT IN CALIFORNIA AT LEAST IT'S
COMFORTING TO KNOW THAT THE HIGH
STANDARDS OF THE PROFESSION.
AND OUR OWN REGULATORY SYSTEM.
MAKES TO ANASTASIA SAFER THAN
EVER BEFORE.
RIGOROUS STANDARDS OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE HALLMARK OF THE
SERVICES OFFERED BY PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS.
WHO MUST COMPLETE BETWEEN TWELVE
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THINK
SIXTEEN THOUSAND HOURS OF
TRAINING?
PRIOR TO PRACTICING
INDEPENDENTLY.
WELL THERE'S ALWAYS THE RISK OF
COMPLICATIONS THAT CAN ARISE IN
A PROCEDURE.
PATIENTS SAID SHOULD REST
ASSURED KNOWING THAT THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY HERE IN THE
GOOD HANDS OF PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS.
WHO HAVE THE TRAINING AND
EXPERTISE TO HELP MINIMIZE THOSE
RISKS?
AND RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES.
THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD TO
DESIGNATE THE WEEK --
IN THIS ROLE EVERY TWENTY
SEVENTH TO FEBRUARY SECOND AS
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WEEK.
WITH THAT MEMBERS EVERITT
RESPECT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER SENATOR
PAN.
I THANK YOU --
AND PRESENT CENTERS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF RESOLUTION AND ONE
TAKE MY SEAT MATE FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I IT'S ONE EIGHT
NOTE THAT --
IN ADDITION TO THE AMOUNT OF
TRAINING ANESTHESIOLOGIST
CONDUCT --
WE SHOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT --
THIS SPECIALTY OF ANESTHESIA HAS
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
PATIENT SAFETY MOVEMENT TO ADD
THE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND SO --
IS -- ONE
SOMETIMES APPROACHES --
A PROCEDURE OR SURGERY WITH SOME
TREPIDATION REST ASSURED THAT
THE THE ANESTHESIOLOGIST HAVE
BEEN WORKING FOR MANY DECADES TO
SURE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
QUALITY AND PATIENT SAFETY --
IN IN IN OUR COUNTRY SO THANKS
VERY MUCH --
FOR THIS RESOLUTION I OR TONIGHT
BUT THUNDERSTONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
I ALSO WANT TO PLUG THE AUTHOR
MY FRIENDS WERE IN THEIR FOR
READING THIS --
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD --
ARE NOT MANY OF YOU KNOW THIS
BUT ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AGA ONE TO
GET FURTHER TRAINING.
AND BECOME PAIN CONTROL
SPECIALIST.
AND IN THIS DAY AND THERE ARE
WHEN WE HAVE THE OPIATE PROBLEM --
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO REACH OUT
TO THE ANESTHESIOLOGIST THAT --
UNDERSTAND ALL THE
ECCENTRICITIES OF OF PAIN AND
UTILIZES PROFESSIONALS TO
HOPEFULLY MINIMIZE THE OPIATE.
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA --
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SO MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEN NONE CENTER GLAZER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO VOTE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOT [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TYLO
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI AMBERG.
BY WIECKOWSKI.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
I MITCHELL I I SEE THREE KNOWS
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
CENTER GLAZER FOR WHAT PURPOSE
TO RISE.
PLEASE PROCEED A MATTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS WERE JOINED
TODAY BY A NUMBER OF A
DISTINGUISHED ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
AROUND THE STATE ID LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE DOCTOR JEFF POKE.
IS UP IN THE GALLERY --
HE HEADS UP THE PEDIATRIC
ANESTHESIA DEPARTMENT OF JOHN
YOUR HEALTH IN MY DISTRICT
SLATED TO BECOME PRESIDENT F
THE ASSOCIATION.
TWENTY TWENTY DR POH WELCOME AND
NINETY YOUR COLLEAGUES WELCOME
TO THE SENATE.
WELCOME THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATOR UMBERG.
DID YOU WANT TO PRESENT ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO PASS ON FILE VERY GOOD FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATOR DORADO.
DID YOU WANT TO PRESENT YOUR
RESOLUTION.
PASS ON FILE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THIS WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR A JOURNEY MEMORIES
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES IS A GREAT SITE AND
THIS THAT I RISE TO ASK THE
RETURN OF MEMORY --
PETER MCGOWAN --
FORMER OWNER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS.
BUT PETER MAGOWAN SEES ME
[inaudible]
BOB.
MY APOLOGIES MADAME PRESIDENT.
BUT I'M GONNA START OVER AGAIN.
I SEE COULD COULD I PLEASE PASS
INTO ABSOLUTELY WILL COME RIGHT
BACK TO SENATOR WIENER NOT A
PROBLEM SENATOR UBIO.
THE PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
IT IS WITH A HEAVY HEART TODAY
THAT I RISE TO ENSURE IN MEMORY
OF ANGELINA CALDERON PINEDO.
ANGELINA WAS TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD RESIDENT OF ROAST MEAT WHO
HAD HER WHOLE LIFE AHEAD OF HER.
ANGELINA WAS A BRIGHT TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD SHE GRADUATED FROM
ROSEMEAD HIGH SCHOOL IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND WAS A STUDENT AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY.
SHE WAS A DISTINGUISHED STUDENT%
AND AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF HER
CAMPUS COMMUNITY.
MOST NOTABLY THROUGH HER SERVICE
AS A RESIDENT AT ALSO START HER
JUNIOR YEAR AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
AFTER COLLEGE ANGELINA HAD
DREAMS OF BECOMING A SOCIAL
WORKER AND HELPING CHILDREN IN
NEED SHE NEVER HESITATED TO LEND.
HER GENEROSITY.
UNFORTUNATELY ANGELINA'S FIVE
WAS UNEXPECTED AND TRAGICALLY
CUT SHORT AS SHE BECAME A VICTIM
OF A HIT AND RUN.
ACCIDENT ANGELINA WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED AS SOMEONE WHO IS
VIBRANT CARRIED.
AN ADVENTUROUS SHE WILL BE TRULY
MISSED BY ALL WHO KNEW HER
SPECIALLY HER PARENTS OR OLDER
SIBLINGS.
HER FRIENDS AND THE OLDER
BROTHER AND MY CONDOLENCES TO
THE FAMILY THANK MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED.
CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I STAND TODAY. TO MOURN.
A FRIEND A PERSONAL FRIEND.
THE LADY WAS MARRIED TO A GI.
THE LADY WHO MARRIED THIS BETTER
IN.
MANY MANY YEARS AGO RAISED THREE
KIDS.
BUT MATTER PRESIDENT I RISE TO
HONOR.
HER AND HER FAMILY DELORES
SANCHES OF LOS ANGELES.
DORIS MARRIED A PARATROOPER AS A
YOUNG LADY.
THEY MET AT GARFIELD HIGH SCHOOL
IN EAST LOS ANGELES.
THE MARRIAGE BEGAN EARLY IN HIS
MILITARY LIFE AND SHE STOOD WITH
THEM SIDE BY SIDE. TO THE TIME
HE SERVED.
AND IRONICALLY SERVED IN THE
EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE MY UNIT
AND I MET.
ARTS SANCHEZ FIRST SERGEANT --
IT AFFECTS POST ONE THIRTEEN IN
IRWINDALE WE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT JUMPING OUT OF AIRPLANES
AND BATTLE WE FOUGHT.
TOGETHER IN RECOGNIZING THAT WE
ALL HAD FAMILIES HE INTRODUCED
ME TO HIS WIFE HIS CHILDREN.
AND I STAYED CLOSE TO THE FAMILY
FOR YEARS UPON YEARS.
AND I MOURN HER LOSS.
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
LEGION POST ONE EIGHTY AS AN
AUXILIARY MEMBER.
AND A JURY MEMBER FOR U. F. W.
POST.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR SHE ALSO WAS
A MEMBER THIS PANIC AMERICAN
AIRBORNE ASSOCIATION.
AMVETS POST ONE THIRTEEN AND
AMVETS POST ONE TWELVE A
SERGEANT OF ARMS FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS.
SHE CROCHETED PERSONALLY
CROCHETED GOLD STAR FLAG FOR THE
GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES.
OF MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE LOST IN
COMBAT.
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN GOLD STARS AND
SHE PRESENTED IN TENNESSEE
MISSOURI GEORGIA NORTH CAROLINA
AND OF COURSE IN CALIFORNIA.
TRAVELING AT HER OWN EXPENSE.
HE PUT TOGETHER HUNDREDS OF
BEANIES AND SCARS FOR THE TROOPS
IN AFGHANISTAN IRAQ FOR THE COLD
WEATHER THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO WEAR THIS UNDER THERE HOW
MUCH.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN EMBEDS
LADIES AUXILIARY DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA NAMED HER WOMAN OF
THE YEAR.
A MILITARY WIFE FOR THIRTY FOUR
YEARS NINE MONTHS AND FIVE DAYS.
AND FOR THESE REASONS
[inaudible]
I RISE. TWO GERMAN HER MEMORY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED [inaudible]
CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES ITS A GREAT SIDE THIS
THAT I RIGHTS DOUBTS THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
OF PETER MCGOWAN THE FORMER --
OWNER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS --
BUT PETER WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY TWO AND MATT HOT AND HE
STUDIED AMERICAN LITERATURE AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY FOR HIS
BACHELORS DEGREE.
AND LATER EARNED A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN POLITICS PHILOSOPHY
AND ECONOMICS AT OXFORD
UNIVERSITY.
AFTER STARTING A GRADUATE
PROGRAM AT JOHNS HOPKINS --
HE DECIDED TO INSTEAD STARTED
CAREER WITH SAFE WAY.
I AFTER MORE THAN A DOZEN YEARS
ULTIMATELY A SAFE WAYS CHAIRMAN
AND CEO.
GOT A FIFTEEN YEAR TENURE AS THE
MANAGING GENERAL PARTNER OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS WHICH OF
COURSE IS CALIFORNIA'S PREMIER
BASEBALL TEAM --
ALIVE OF A LIFELONG GIANTS FAN --
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO HE LED
THE GROUP --
THAT BOUGHT THE GIANTS IN ORDER
TO KEEP THE TEAM IN SAN
FRANCISCO --
HUMOR IS MOTIVATED TO KEEP THE
TEAM IN SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE
BEING A NEW YORKER ORIGINALLY HE
KNEW FIRSTHAND.
THE PAIN --
FOR NEW YORKERS WHEN THE GIANTS
MOVED TO SAN FRANCISCO.
IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND I'M
THANKFUL THAT THEY DID.
I IN TWO THOUSAND IN A
BASEBALL'S COMMISSIONER BUD
SELIG SAID QUOTE PETER MCGOWAN
DID SAY BASEBALL FOR SAN
FRANCISCO --
PETER ALSO SPEARHEADED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE ABSOLUTE
MOST BEAUTIFUL BALLPARK IN THE
NATION --
NOW KNOWN AS ORACLE PARK
PREVIOUSLY EIGHTEEN T. PARK AND
BEFORE THAT PAC BELL PARK --
AND YOU DID IT WITH NO TAXPAYER
MONEY -- HE
HIRED THE EXECUTIVE TEAM --
THAT BILL TWO FOUR WORLD SERIES
TEAMS --
CREATING THE DYNASTY.
EITHER ONE THREE WORLD SERIES IN.
220-001-22000 AND FOURTEEN AND
FOR THE RECORD THAT IS MORE
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
THIS CENTURY OF AND ALL OTHER
CALIFORNIA TEAMS COMBINE.
HE MADE THE GIANTS THE FIRST
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TEAM --
TO DEDICATE AND ANNUAL GAME TO
THE FIGHT AGAINST HIV AIDS ARE
HE ALSO FORMED.
THE JUNIOR GIANTS PROGRAM THAT
ORGANIZES FREE LEAGUES FOR
CHILDREN TO LEARN AND PLAY
BASEBALL.
EVEN AS AN OWNER HE COULD
USUALLY BE FOUND SITTING IN THE
STANDS --
WITH THE FANS --
WITH ALL OF US IN HIS BUSINESS
SUIT.
HI PETER SURVIVED.
BY HIS WIFE DEBBIE BAEZ THREE
BROTHERS HIS FIVE CHILDREN AND
IS THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN.
JOIN ME AND A TURNING TODAY IN
MEMORY OF HIM A GALLON.
GO GIANTS BEAT LA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER SENATOR
DODD.
THAT A PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO ADD MY VOICE TO THIS THE
JOURNEY MEMORY I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT --
MISTER MCGOWAN IS --
HE YOU KNOW JUST --
YOU'D HIS HIS MEMORY IS JUST
OBSERVE HERE IN IN THIS CHAMBERS --
AFTER HIS RETIREMENT HE MOVED TO
MY DISTRICT INSANE ELENA AND HIS
WIFE DEBBIE RETIRED THERE.
IT IS A LIFE LONG GIANT FEE AND
IT ALSO --
* REALLY A LIFE LONG --
SEASON TICKET HOLDER FOR THE
SAME BRINGING US FOR WORLD
SERIES AFTER A LONG LONG DROUGHT --
THIS IS SO VERY VERY
APPRECIATIVE AND WILL REMIND --
THOSE DODGER FANS IN ROOM.
THAT THAT SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THERE'S ONLY ONE TEAM
THAT'S EVER SWEPT THE DODGERS --
DURING THAT TIME AND THAT WAS
SAM CISCO OVER LOS ANGELES.
SENATOR DODD SENATOR ALAN.
A MEMBER SAYS A SENATOR WHO
REPRESENTS THE CITY THAT
CURRENTLY HOUSES THE CURRENT
NATIONALLY CHAMPIONS THE FACT.
TWO TIME NATIONAL CHAMPIONS --
IN A ROW I JUST WANT EXTEND MY
CITIES CONDOLENCES TO THE FOLKS
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHO DO INDEED
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL BALLPARK --
MISTER MCGOWAN WAS A WORTHY
RIVAL AND AND WE GIVE HIM ALL OF
OUR RESPECT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FOURTH WEEK BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED MEMBERS TO HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL A JOURNEY IN MEMORIES.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
WILK THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SAID SIR WORK I APOLOGIZE I JUST
SAW MIGHT GO UP.
CENTER DRAWS A PRIVILEGES.
PLEASE FOR CA ABOUT A FOURTH IS
CAPITAL GOES RED DAY WE ASK YOU
TO PLEASE JOIN US IN WEARING RED.
TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THE IMPACT
OF THE HEART DISEASE ON WOMEN
PLEASE DON'T FORGET TO PACK
SOMETHING READ BEFORE YOU RETURN
TO SACRAMENTO NEXT WEEK THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO MEMBERS
ANY THING ELSE.
SENATOR WELL THERE IS NO FOR THE
BUSINESS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM TODAY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE.
AND WE WILL RECONVENE HERE IN
RED ON MONDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND THANK
SENATOR WILL MEMBERS THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT ME MOTION WILL BE
MADE ADJOURNMENT.
MOTION WILL BE MADE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM HAVE
A GREAT WEEKEND.
CENTER MITCHELL FOR WHAT PURPOSE
YOU RISE [inaudible]
BUT THANK YOU BYE JUST REMIND
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT
BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL COMMENCE
AT TEN AM BUDGET COMMITTEE TEN
AM.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU MEMBERS